chers collègues monsieur le
ministre
avec le président Lafond qui est à la
tête de la commission de la
culture de l'éducation la communication
et des sport nous avons décidé d'ouvrir
une commission de mettre en place une
commission d'enquête
relative à la situation postérieure à
l'agression de du professeur Samuel
Patti notre volonté est d'essayer de
comprendre comment si des leçons ont été
tirées de cet événement dramatique en
terme d'organisation et singulièrement
pour ce qui concerne votre ministère si
le ministère de la Justice a eu depuis
ou a pu depuis mettre en place une
organisation avec l'Éducation nationale
dans le cadre de signalement dans le
cadre d'agression dans le cadre diff en
sujet que nous allons détailler nous
sommes sous forme de commission
d'enquête car nous souhaitons aller le
plus loin possible et nous donner tous
les moyens possibles de ce travail et
c'est
donc dans ces conditions que nous vous
entendons cet après-midi mais peut-être
que le président la fond veut dire
quelques mots avant non je je pense
qu'on va laisser le garde des saut
s'exprimer et après nous aurons des
questions précises à à lui poser
évidemment ce qui nous intéresse
beaucoup c'est l'articulation des
différents acteurs dès lors que un
enseignant est menacé ou fait ou a fait
l'objet du d'une agression et différents
acteurs police justice éducation
nationale est-ce que dans quelle mesure
ce ce partenariat est effectif et aussi
comment se met en en route la chaîne
pénale dès lors qu'il y a une agression
dont un un un enseignant a pu être
victime je me permet d'indiquer vous
indiquer ainsi qu'à l'ensemble des
collègues que cette audition est
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat voilà monsieur le
ministre vous avez la
parole bien monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
Président de la Commission de la culture
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
3 ans après l'assassinat de Samuel
pti l'attentat contre Dominique Bernard
démontre à quel point la menace
terroriste continue de peser sur les
professionnels de l'éducation
nationale l'école c'est personnels ses
élèves sont sont
devenus des cibles privilégié des TER
terroriste le terrorisme les frappe et à
travers
eux s'attaque évidemment à chacun
d'entre nous car ces atteintes
portées contre les
enseignants ces atteintes portées dans
l'espace scolaire sont
évidemment insupportable et le mot est
vous me l'accorderez doucement e fémique
euh insupportable parce qu'elle viole le
sanctuaire
républicain le havre de
connaissance notre berceau laïque de la
transmission des valeurs
républicaines valeur évidemment pour
nous
tous cardinale et au nom de la liberté
de l'égalité de la fraternité on se doit
bien sûr
de préserver l'école de toute forme de
radicalisation
d'obscurantisme et de
violence l'école au fond est le le le le
premier espace de transmission des
valeurs de notre République et elle
mérite une mobilisation
forte une mobilisation sans faille de la
part de tous les acteurs de
l'État pour que les enseignants puissent
continuer à former nos enfants à
éveiller
leur leur esprit sans en courir de
risque et sans craindre pour leur vie ou
pour celle de leur
proches tous les acteurs de l'État sont
unis pour protéger l'école républicaine
et mon ministère évidemment ne ne fait
pas exception à à cette règle impérieuse
bien au contraire euh on se doit d'abord
d'apporter à tous les niveaux de la
menace qui pèse sur nos enseignants et
nos écoles une réponse
coordonnée immédiate ferme et et
dissuasive et d'abord il est essentiel
que tout acte
répréhensible au porteur d'une menace à
l'encontre je dis de cette façon de la
sphère scolaire soit porté à la
connaissance de l'autorité judiciaire
ou à la connaissance de l'autorité
administrative pour qu'une réponse y
soit donnée c'est évidemment totologique
que de rappeler que si la justice n'est
pas saisie par définition
elle ne peut pas intervenir et l'idée a
été je je vais le développer de de
fluidifier les circuits
d'information pour que la justice puisse
être saisie et pour qu'elle apporte la
réponse la plus adéquate et la meilleure
possible alors j'ai été amené à prendre
un certain nombre de de
circulaires pour renforcer et les
partenariats entre l'éducation nationale
Le ministère de la
Justice justement pour qu'on ait
une remontée d'information rapide
d'abord avant une remontée d'information
rapide une remontée d'information parce
que il a fallu changer un peu de de de
paradigme si j'ose dire et de pratique
puisque un certain nombre de choses nous
savons qui ont été qui qui constituent
des infractions ou en tous les cas des
alertes susceptibles d'intéresser la
justice n'ont pas toujours été p la
connaissance de la
justice donc remontée
d'information remontée d'information
rapide et naturellement
efficiente côté autorité judiciaire la
première circulaire elle date du 8 avril
2005 ce n'est pas moi évidemment qui
l'ai porta elle est relative à la
prévention et au traitement des
infractions commises au sein et aux
abords des établissements scolaires euh
sen est suivi une circulaire
interministérielle
du 11 octobre
2019 relative à la lutte contre les
violences
scolaires nous avons dans ces
texes le ministère de la Justice au sens
large évidemment souligner l'impérieux
besoin sur l'ensemble du territoire
d'établir des conventions
départementales
entre les services de l'éducation
nationale les forces de l'ordre et les
parquets de telles conventions je m'y
arrête un instant sont sont essentielles
pour convenir des modalités de
transmission des signalements de
l'éducation nationale à destination des
procureurs de la République de telles
conventions sont absolument
indispensables notamment dans les
situation d'urgence pour faire face à un
danger révélé en milieu scolaire il
importe évidemment que le chef
d'établissement sache quoi faire comment
faire et qu' sache comment contacter le
parquet ça n'est pas une évidence il
faut que dans
cette synergie que l'on veut mettre
ensemble les uns sachent exactement si
j'ose dire si vous me permettez cette
familiarité sur quel bouton on appuie
pour que
l'autorité
judiciaire puisse être saisie et qu'elle
le soit de façon
précise la coopération entre tous les
service de
l'État est absolument nécessaire pour
faciliter les circuits de de de
signalement dès le 17 octobre 2020 au
lendemain du du du terrible assassinat
de Samuel
paatti j'ai diffusé une circulaire
relayant le Télégramme adressé le même
jour par le ministère de l'Intérieur et
appelant à une vigilance accrue pour
protéger les établissements scolaires et
les personnels de l'Éducation
nationale il fallait agir vite il
fallait agir de manière ciblée afin que
les magistrats du du parquet et les
membres de l'éducation nationale soient
en mesure
d'identifier les premiers signaux même
les plus faibles d'une forme de
radicalisation
violente le message porté par cette
circulaire d'octobre
2020 était clair accessible à tous et il
reposait évidemment sur un partenariat
déjà solide il fallait
valoriser ce partenariat avec afin qu'il
devienne un un un rempart
pérenne contre la violence et la menace
terroriste il s'agit du partenariat
éducation nationale intérieur justice
qui
conduit pardon qui conduit à un dialogue
constant entre les trois entités
étatiques et c'est le ciment d'une
coordination efficace entre milieu
scolaire police justice dès le merci
monsieur le
président
dès le 17 octobre 2020 j'ai j'ai rappelé
au côté du ministre de
l'Intérieur la nécessité la nécessité de
procéder à une analyse de l'état de la
menace pesant sur les établissements
scolairire et les personnels qui euh y
exerc et de la nécessité de partager
l'information de
coordonner la réponse administrative et
judiciaire j'ai rappelé bien sûr cette
coordination devait s'illustrer par le
dynamisme des instances de lutte contre
la radicalisation que sont d'abord les
groupes d'évaluation départementaux plus
connu sous l'acronyme GED et les
cellules de prévention de la
radicalisation et d'accompagnement des
familles les les spraf au sein de de ces
instances qui sont présidées par le
préfet de
département non seulement les procureurs
de la République qui sont mobilisés
systématiquement mais encore l'éducation
nationale y est représenté via les
directions académiques des services de
l'éducation nationale les daenes les
services de renseignement partagent
ainsi leurs informations avec l'autorité
préfectorale l'autorité judiciaire
l'éducation
nationale en assurant une telle
circulation de l'information régulière
entre tous les acteurs du département on
est mieux à même d'anticiper des menaces
des violences ou
ou des drames tels que ceux que nous
avons connu le préfet et le procureur de
la République dispose de renseignement
leur permettant de cibler en amont la
réponse la plus
appropriée à l'égard d'individu profils
qui sont des profils inquiétants la
réponse peut ainsi revêtir une nature
judicière et je soulligne qu'au sein de
ces instances le procureur de la
République et les représentants de
l'éducation nationale
peuvent également transmettre des
informations au service de renseignement
l'éducation nationale communique par
exemple les signalements les plus
préoccupants concernant un élève ou une
famille au service spécialisé du
renseignement le procureur de la
République peut faire état des éléments
contenus dans des procédures judiciaires
et au sein des groupes d'évaluation
départementaux les les GEDES et des
cellules de prévention de la
radicalisation et d'accompagnement des
familles
la même finalité mobilise les acteurs de
terrain la prévention de la menace
terroriste mon ministère veille à ce que
tout fait significatif visant la sphère
scolaire soit porter la connaissance de
l'autorité administrative ou judiciaire
les chefs d'établissement doivent faire
systématiquement remonter aux directeurs
académiques des services de l'éducation
nationale toute menace pesant sur les
personnels et leur établissement toute
forme de radicalisation et même tout
discours portant atteinte à la laïcité
et de telles informations sont ensuite
transmises au préfet de département qui
évalue chaque situation et décide des
mesures les plus adaptées le recteur ou
le directeur académique des services de
l'éducation nationale signale également
les faits au procureur de la République
en application de l'article 40 du code
de procédure pénale si il est avéré
qu'un fait susceptible de constituer une
infraction l'instruction
interministérielle du 27 octobre 2020
relative à la sécurisation de l'espace
scolaire et aux mesures d'accompagnement
du coramp enseignant rappelle que dès la
commission des faits les membres de la
communauté éducative doivent je dis bien
doivent signaler à leur hiérarchie toute
menace ou toute atteinte à leur personne
j'insiste sur le doiv parce que on a
connu des situations peut-être hélas en
connaîon encore où des enseignants sont
victimes et n'osent pas dire les choses
et naturellement les choses tu les
choses non révélées ne peut
pas c'est tout logique de le dire
appeler une une intervention de la part
de la de la justice dès le signalement
des faits les personnels éducatifs font
l'objet d'un soutien
spécifique ils sont informés de leur
droit de déposer plainte ils peuvent
être accompagnés dans cette démarche par
les services de la Direction des
services départementaux d'éducation
national un référent sécurité scolaire
identifié dans chaque brigade de
gendarmerie ou dans chaque commissariat
de police renseigne les agents sur les
modalités pratiques d'un tel dépôt de
plainte une orientation vers
l'association locale d'aide aux victimes
est également proposé à l'agent pour le
soutenir lorsque la protection de la
victime apparaît nécessaire il lui est
proposé une domiciliation à son adresse
professionnelle ou à l'adresse du
service de police ou de la brigade de
gendarmerie pour
évidemment mettre la victime plus à
l'aise et qu'elle ne se dise pas si l'on
dispose de mon adresse on peut
l'utiliser à des fins évidemment
malveillante dans ma circulaire du 5
septembre 2023 relative au infractions
commises en milieu scolaire j'ai de
nouveau invité les parquets généraux et
les parquets à renforcer les
partenariats avec l'Éducation nationale
et les établissements scolaires par la
conclusion de protocole destiné à
formaliser les circuits des signalements
à l'autorité judiciaire et je voudrais
vous dire que de façon générale je je
quitte un instant notre sujet pour une
digression qui sera courte mais de façon
générale et et et en cohérence avec
cela j'ai toujours demandé à ce que l'on
ne soit plus dans la culture que l'on
appelle en langage technocratique du
couloir de nage qui s'agisse des
violences
intrafamiliales qu'il s'agisse du
harcèlement scolaire qu'il s'agisse du
sujet qui nous préoccupe notre intérêt
commun est que tout le monde travaille
ensemble ça n'est pas une évidence et ça
implique en réalité un changement de
culture changement de paradigme et les
choses se mettent en place j'ai rappelé
le rôle des magistrats référent
éducation nationale ça c'est une
création récente qui s'attache à assurer
l'efficacité des circuits de
transmission des information ces
magistrats référents qui par définition
sont sont spécialisés si j'ose dire
veillent à maintenir en lien avec le
référent justice désigné par le recteur
des contacts
régulier avec leurs correspondant au
sein des établissements scolaires
c'est-à-dire que on attend plus que les
choses se passe on a des contacts
réguliers entre l'éducation nationale et
la justice pour faire le tour des
établissement et pour déceler
d'éventuelles difficultés et pour mieux
les anticiper les magistrats référents
sont également en contact avec les
référents désignés pour ces
établissements au sein des services de
police et au sein des services de
gendarmerie donc on a
la police gendarmerie
enseignement justice avec des référen
spécialisé qui communiquent j'allais
dire même s'il ne s'est rien passé mais
il faut qu'on aille dceler les signaux
les plus faibles parce que
évidemment quand le drame
arrive on a on a tous le le le sentiment
de de de l'échec évidemment du drame
absolu indiscible et pardon mais pour
décrire ces drames les mots sont
totalement dérisoires bien sûr donc dès
qu'il y a un petit petite difficulté
quelle qu'elle soit moi je souhaite que
tout le monde tout le monde puisse
partager les difficultés pour intervenir
tout de suite les procureurs de la
République s'assurent en outre assure en
outre un un lien opérationnel entre
magistrat référent et ducnat et
magistrat référents radicalisation
violente et terrorisme afin que toutes
ces actions euh soient parfaitement
coordonné et pour rendre le traitement
quotidien de ces informations encore
plus utile et encore plus rapide on est
en train d'élaborer avec l'Éducation
nationale une trame harmonisée de
signalement directement exploitable et
c'est ça son intérêt dès lors que le
comportement dénoncé constitue une
infraction pénale deuxièmement au-delà
de la lutte contre la radicalisation et
le terrorisme il nous faut évidemment
protéger nos écoles et nos enfants des
dérives
séparatistes il nous faut bien sûr
combattre leur racine
euh et les discours euh séparatistes qui
n'ont euh strictement rien à faire à
l'école ni à l'école ni ailleurs au
demeurant véritable source de
déstabilisation euh majeure
euh on a eu cette C exemple il y a
quelques jours d'une toile présentée à
des élèves et de réaction
qui qui sont quand même
extraordinairement
choquantes
et ne pas ne pas constater ces ces
difficultés les lesigners ou les minorés
est à mon avis une faute morale majeure
et une faute politique
majeure l'école l ce qu'elle incarne la
promesse républicaine d'égalité des
chances est au cœur d'une stratégie
interministérielle de lutte contre les
séparatisme ça
devrait commencer au sein de la
famille a toute une discussion sur la
parentalité vous le
savez j'ai résumé ça dans une formule un
peu familière tenez vos gosses mais
tenez-les à tous
égards puis veillez à ce que leur soit
rappeler que nous vivons dans un pays
qui est un pays
laïque que nos valeurs sont les valeurs
républicaines et aucune
autre puis ensuite il y a l'éducation
nationale et ensuite il y a la justice
dans son volet préventif ce que l'on
peut faire notamment pour pour les
mineurs et ensuite dans le volet
répressif il y a toute une une
une synergie qui doit se mettre en place
entre toutes ces actions et puis euh
parlera peut-être aussi de de ceux qui
jettent de l'huile sur le
feu et moi j'en veux beaucoup à Monsieur
Mélenchon et à ces séïdes je le dis ici
à cœur ouvert je trouve qu'à la fois
raconter aux musulmans de notre pays que
nous les détestons c'est absolument
scandaleux c'est totalement
irresponsable ça génère des dégâts euh
incommensurables au sein même de notre
de notre société
euh pardon pour
cette ce ce ce ce petit moment de de de
colère froide alors outre les groupes
d'intér d'évaluation euh départementaux
les jedes et les cellules de prévention
de de la radicalisation
euh les parquets les servic déconcentrés
de l'État et cetera
euh nous avons également euh les
cellules de lutte contre entre
l'islamisme radical et le repli
communautaire
l'clire qui cible localement le contrôle
des structures identifiées comme
porteuse de discours et comportement
séparatistes
euh c'est avec le même objectif que la
loi du mois d'août 2021 confortant le
respect des principes de la
République c'est avec ce même objectif
disais-je qu'un nouvel arsenal a été
consacré pour faire face à la
prolifération des discours aineux et des
contenus illicites sur Internet et sur
les réseaux sociaux par une circulaire
du 22 octobre
2021 j'ai sensibilisé les parquets
généraux et les parquets la nécessité de
se saisir des infractions incriminant
des comportements susceptibles de viser
les enseignants afin de s'assurer
évidemment que les valeurs
fondamentales auquelles nous tenons tous
euh soit mieux protégé j'ai également
invité les procureurs à renforcer la
répression à l'encontre des auteurs et
diffuseurs de contenu haineux sur les
réseaux sociaux la mobilisation de mon
ministère se fonde dès lors sur
l'arsenal législatif suivant d'abord le
nouveau délit d'entrave à la fonction
d'enseignant comme vous le savez le fait
d'entraver d'une manière
concerté à l'aide de menace l'exercice
de la fonction d'enseignant et puni d'un
nom d'emprisonnement et de 15000 €
d'amende en autre par la circulaire du
mois de septembre 2023 du 5 très
précisément relative aux infractions
commises en milieu scolaire j'ai assuré
la large diffusion au procureur généux
et au procureur de la République de la
note du ministre de l'Éducation
Nationale du 31 août 2023 cette note
invite les chefs d'établissement à
veillé au respect de la loi du 15 mars
encadrant en application du principe de
laïcité le port des signes ou détenu
manifestant une apparence religieuse
dans les écoles collèges et lycées
publics je songe évidemment mais comme
vous sans doute à cette instant à la
baayè les parquets généraux les parquets
sont vu rappeler dans cette même
circulaire que l'infraction qui est
prévu par l'article
433-3-1 du code pénal qui incrimine les
menaces et les violences séparatistes
peut être retenu en cas de comportement
menaçant violent intimidant commis dans
le but d'obtenir une adaptation des
règles retirer cette toile que je ne
saurais voir par
exemple par ailleurs il
a par ailleurs il a été
rappelé que les pressions sur les
croyances des élèves ou les tentatives
d'endoctrinement sont constitutifs d'une
contravention une infraction de 5e
classe lorsque ces agissements sont
commis dans les écoles publiques ou dans
les locaux d'enseignement leurs abords
immédiats et pendant toute activité liée
à
l'enseignement j'ai enfin invité les
parquets généraux et parquet
pardonnez-moi à apportter une réponse
ferme et immédiate à toutes les
infractions commises à l'encontre des
enseignants
et du personnel de l'éducation nationale
les menaces ou violences dirigées contre
les professionnels de l'éducation
national porte non seulement atteinte à
leur autorité mais également au
fonctionnement de notre système éducatif
c'est d'ailleurs à ce titre que la loi
pénale protège spécifiquement les
personnels de l'Éducation nationale et
le sanctuaire scolaire ce qui devrait
être un
sanctuaire il existe à cet égard de
nombreuses infractions pour lesqu la
qualité d'enseignant ou le lieu de
commission des faits notamment au sein
d'un établissement scolaire ou aux abord
de celui-ci sont constitutifs de
circonstances aggravantes je pense à
tous les faits de violence
notamment les lieux éducatifs
bénéficient dès lors d'une protection
supplémentaire en raison de la sécurité
devant être assuré aux usagers dans ces
espaces je souhaite enfin
le délit de mise en danger par la
diffusion d'information personnelle créé
par la loi du 24 août
2021 le nouvel article
223-1-1 du code pénal incrimine les
comportements individuels visant à nuire
gravement à une personne à sa famille ou
à ses bienens en dévoilant des
informations personnelles la concernant
ce nouveau délit est puni de 3 an
d'emprisonnement de 45000 € d'amende ces
peines sont portées à 5 ans 75000 €
d'amende lorsque les faits sont commis
au préjudice de certaines catégories de
personnes dont bien sûr les personnes
chargées d'une mission de service public
cette infraction a répondu à un vide
juridique vise les messages véhéments
diffusé sur les réseaux sociaux tels que
ceux qui avaient été proférés à
l'encontre de Samuel paatti dès que de
tels messages diffusent des éléments
permettant d'identifier une
personne après ce
drame on a
essayé de voir comment factuellement les
choses s'était enchaîné et on s'est
rendu compte que l'on avait je déteste
cette expression euh un trou dans la
raquette métaphore sportive vous me la
pardonnerez mais ça signifiait que on ne
pouvait pas judiciariser et de ce
constat nous avons créé cette
infraction si nous l'avions eu mais pour
vous dire les
choses il n'y a pas une législation
parfaite euh notre devoir c'est que à
chaque fait dramatique de cette nature
ou moins dramatique d'ailleurs on puisse
poser les choses et puis se dire mais
comment on peut
progresser on a un problème là sur la
prise médicamenteuse et le contrôle que
l'on peut avoir sur une prise de
médicaments ça n'était pas prévu on y
travaille et chaque affaire nous conduit
évidemment à une
réflexion qui va bien
au-delà de ces réflexions irres ble que
je peux résumer de la façon suivante
Yaka faucon fallaet yavka et cetera
voilà les choses évidemment
sont sont bien plus complexes que cela
et ceux qui nous promettent je le dis à
cet
instant la rémission de ces crimes mais
rémission au sens de ils n'existeront
plus sont des menteurs parce que le
risque zéro n'existe pas et moi je
voudrais également rendre hommage aux
forces de sécurité intérieur à nos
équipes de renseignement le
renseignement pénitentiaire aussi que
que nous avons considérablement renforcé
et qui nous permet d'éviter un certain
nombre
d'attentats terrifiants il faut aussi le
dire même si bien sûr ça ne nous console
pas euh des drames que nous avons vécu
en
2022 34 affaires concernant des
personnes mise en cause pour au moins
une infraction de mise en danger de la
vie d'autruie par diffusion
d'information relative à la vie privée
ou professionnel ont été
orientés par les parquets et le chiffre
est intéressant parce que c'était 6
affaires en
2021 ces nouvelles dispositions de la
loi de
2021 sont notamment mobilisés par le
pôle national de lutte contre la haine
en ligne je veux vous en toucher un mot
veut la création de ce pôle ce pôle
national de lutte contre la haine en
ligne a été créé à droit constant par la
circulaire du mois de novembre 2020
relative à la lutte contre la haine en
ligne et par le décret du 24 novembre
2020 le tribunal judiciaire de Paris a
été désigné pour centraliser sous la
direction du procureur de Paris le
traitement de ces affaires significative
de cyber harcèlement et de haine en
ligne et entre janvier 2021 date
d'ouverture effective du pôle et le 13
novembre
2023 le
pnlh S saisi de
2009 procédures ça signifie que le pôle
est bien identifié dans le paysage
judiciaire et que il tourne si j'ose
dire à plein
rendement le pôle national de lutte
contre la haine en ligne a notamment
vocation à traiter des inf action
suivante lorsqu'elles sont commises en
ligne discours de haine réprimé par la
loi de de juillet
1881 provocation directe à un acte de
terrorisme et apologie publique d'un
acte de
terrorisme toute forme de menace de
harcèlement moral sexuel cyberhcèlement
en l'absence de relations
interpersonnell ou professionnell entre
la victime et l'auteur des faits
lorsqu'elles sont commises soit avec des
circonstances
aggravantes du des articles
132-76 ou
132-77 du code pénal discrimination
raciale ethnique sexuel soit en raison
de l'expression publique de la victime
ou de son exposition publique et dans ce
cadre le parquet de Paris et
l'interlocuteur privilégié de la
plateforme d'harmonisation d'analyse de
regroupement d'orientation des
signalement Faros la création du pôle
national de lutte contre la haine en
ligne A permis à l'institution
judiciaire de nouer un véritable
dialogue en avec les opérateurs de
réseaux sociaux dialogue indispensable à
l'efficience de l'action judiciaire
l'identification de personnes ressources
expression entre guillemets en effet
permis au pôle national de lutte contre
la haine en ligne d'intervenir
directement auprès de ces
opérateurs afin notamment de faciliter
l'exécution de réquisition judiciaire le
blocage de S qui qui diffuse ces
messages de haine a par ailleurs été
renforcé et j'aimerais à ce sujet
aborder les dispositions du règlement
européen sur le digital Act service le
DSA adopté en octobre
2022 applicable au 17 février 2024
c'estàdire dans quelques jours ce
règlement vise à lutter contre la
diffusion de contenu illicite et
instaurer plus de transparence entre les
plateformes en ligne et leurs
utilisateur le législateur français a
pris des dispositions afin d'adopter les
mesures
nationales à ce règlement et c'est
l'objet du projet de loi visant à
sécuriser et réguler l'espace
numérique adopté en première lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale le 17 octobre
2023 le projet ce projet prévoit un
ensemble de mesures concrètes visant à
renforcer l'ordre public dans l'espace
numérique en permettant par exemple un
renforcement des sanctions des personnes
condamnées pour cyberhcèlement phénomène
qui vous le savez se propage sur les
réseaux sociaux enfin je souhaite
souligner que la formation des
magistrats en matière de lutte contre le
séparatisme a été renforcée afin de
répondre et de lutter contre tous les
crimes de haine qui vise à déstabiliser
nos institutions et à diviser notre
population en définitive je je je veux
vous assurer de l'entière mobilisation
du ministère de la
Justice pour protéger le monde de
l'éducation de la menace terroriste
islamiste et de tout comportement
incompatible avec les valeurs qui sont
les nôtres je suis
naturellement à votre entière
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions avec le mince filet de voix
qui me
reste merci Monsieur le Ministre
plusieurs collègues se sont inscrits on
comm c'est par Monique DEC on va prendre
toutes les
questions dans la foulée si vous le
voulez
bien oui je suis là ah monsieur le garde
des saau voilà je suis ici voilà j'ai
j'ai bien écouté donc votre exposé
j'aurais voulu savoir précisément quand
un enseignant est menacé alors oralement
physiquement dans le casadre de ses
cours mais égal ou à l'extérieur
d'établissement ou en ligne quelle
procédure quelquefois c'est donc vous
avez dit la voie hiérarchique
quel est donc le déroulé de la voie
hiérarchique s'il passe par son chef
d'établissement
deuxièmement il doit y avoir je pense
des procédures d'alerte directes avec un
un site un lieu où l'enseignant peut-il
directement s'adresser peut-être sans
passer ou en passant par la procédure
hiérarchique je je pose cette question
et pour savoir et en ce qui concerne le
ple national de la lutte contre la haine
en ligne vous avez parlé de 2009 proc
euh Procé c'estd dur engager combien
d'enseignants dans ces procédures et
est-ce qu'ils peuvent directement les
enseignants alerter ce pôle excusez-moi
c'est peut-être précis vous êtes
peut-être voilà alors sur votre pôle
national de lutte contre la haine en
ligne vous avez parlé de cyber
harcèlement qu'il y avait 2009
procédures qui ont été dans en cours et
combien d'enseignants dans ces
procédures est-ce que un enseignant peut
alerter directement le pôle national de
lutte contre la haine en
ligne on continue les questions colombe
Brusselles merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur le Ministre euh
je reviens sur le début de de votre
exposé et sur la collaboration et le
renforcement que vous avez détaillé
entre ministère de la Justice ministère
de l'Intérieur et ministère de de
l'éducation nationale je comprends qu'il
y a des protocoles spécifiques qui ont
été signés conclus entre services
départementaux de l'éduc parquet
ministère de l'Intérieur notamment dans
la Somme et dans le département du Nord
euh du coup pardon j'ai commencé en
disant j'ai une question en fait une
fois ceci posé j'ai plusieurs questions
d'abord quel est le le le bilan que vous
pouvez faire sur ces ces protocoles de
de coopération
euh combien de de délit puis de plaines
ont pu remonter quel est votre point de
vue comme garde d' saau sur l'efficacité
de ces protocoles particuliers et
troisème question est-il envisagé ou
envisagez-vous dans la responsabilité
qui est la vôtre euh de contribuer à la
généralisation de ces
protocoles Marie
Mercier merci Monsieur le le président
en fait je je voulais faire un un
portter à connaissance suite à la petite
anecdote qui n'en est pas une de mon
point de vue concernant ce fameux
tableau qui a été présenté dans un
collège je voudrais revenir quelques
mois en
arrière du temps du cumul des mandats
donc j'étais maèire de ma petite commune
1300 habitants une commune tranquille où
tout se passe bien atelier champ qui se
passe sur le temps méridien donc entre
MIDH et 2 où l'animateur musical payé
donc par les fonds
communaux propose de de faire chanter
aux élèves la chanson Armstrong de
Claude nougarou je pense que vous l'avez
tous en tête je ne vais pas me lancer
dans un tour de champ je je ne vais pas
me lancer là-dedans donc concomitamment
à à à à cette activité champ
l'institutrice il s'agit d'une classe de
CE2 donc des enfants de de de 8 9 ans
décident de faire apprendre aussi ce
champ pour qu'il y ait un atelier champ
un petit peu plus conséquent les enfants
ramènent les paroles à la maison pour
les apprendre un élève revient donc à
l'atelier chant et dit je ne chanterai
pas cette chanson mes parents ne veulent
pas donc l'animateur payé par la commune
vient me voir il s'agissait des paroles
alléloui alléluia c'est-à-dire confusion
du champ profane et du champ sacré je
prends ma décision d'élu et je dis
écoutez très bien s'il ne veut pas
chanter cette chanson il ne participera
pas à l'activité musicale il ira faire
la patte à selle qui est dans dans dans
la salle d'à côté sauf que l'instituteur
nous sommes en
CE2 l'enfant revient et dit B non moi je
ne chanterai pas ces paroles que dit
l'instituteur ben je vais voir avec ma
hiérarchie qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je
fasse que dit l'inspecteur on ne va
surtout pas l'obliger cet enfant va
rester dans la classe chant il chantera
lalala lalala au lieu de faire allélouis
alleluia donc c'est avec cette petite
anecdote qui a donc eu lieu il y a déjà
quelques années les choses en fait se
sont aggravées puisque maintenant on ne
propose même plus cette chanson qui qui
est un champ antiraciste qui fait partie
de notre patrimoine qui n'a absolument
rien de sacré
donc on a mis ça de côtés donc on va on
continue de chanter les CoClic mesdam on
ne chante plus du tout les chansons de
Claude Nero mais en fait les parents ont
un rôle important dans l'histoire
puisque sont les parents qui en fait ont
pris la main sur l'éducation nationale
en classe de CE2 donc c'est juste unorté
à connaissance j'ai d'autres histoires
mais je ne vais pas tenir le micro parce
qu'elles sont encore plus croustillantes
mais quand même ce gamin maintenant il a
18 ans j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'il
fait Stéphane piernoir
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre très rapidement je
évidemment vous avez brossé et balayé
l'ensemble des des dispositifs du
dirisssement de la la législation
notamment des peines qui sont encouru
par les les auteurs de d'insulte de
menace de de de tout ce que vous avez
décrit tout à l'heure moi j'ai
simplement une question sur l'adaptation
les conventions c'est super et on a on a
eu le l'audition des responsables de la
police et de la gendarmerie qui qui
montre bien qu'il y a il y a un
partenariat qui fonctionne qui est qui
est qui est opérant et et làdessus j'ai
rien à dire mais en tant aussi un peu en
tant qu'ancien enseignant je je
m'interroge sur la réactivité l'agilité
l'agilité de du du processus et comment
comment faire pour que un enseignant on
a tous ceses ces idées en tête mais un
enseignant qui se sent véritablement en
danger puisse faire exercer un droit de
retrait mais mais pas dans pas dans une
semaine pas après avoir contacté le
référent en laïcité comme ça a été le
cas pour pour Samuel Patti de son
établissement puis du rectorat puis puis
du ministère il est trop tard Samuel pti
qui avait lui-même un un marteau dans
son sac à dos puisqu'il se sentait donc
c'était son son outil de défense
puisqu'il se sentait
menacé comment comment faire pour
immédiatement prendre la mesure des
choses et faire en sorte que le
l'enseignant éventuellement une équipe
d'enseignants puisse se mettre en
retrait de manière vraiment automatique
sans qu'il n'y ait la moindre
contestation et couverture du chef
d'établissement
là-dessus Martin
leevrier merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le ministre pour toutes
ces explication vous parlez trou dans la
raquette tout à l'heure et moi je me
pose une question toute simplef je sais
pas si aussi simple que ça c'est on
parle de la protection de tous les
systèmes de protection de contrôle
d'aide des enseignants est-ce que les
enseignants du du secteur privé sous
contrat sont inclus du privé hors
contrat sont inclus et je vais plus loin
des apprentis c'est les form formateur
qui là ne sont pas les enseignants
sont-ils inclus dans toutes ces
protections dans tous ces systèmes ou il
y a-t-il un trou dans raquette merci
beaucoup Annique billon merci monsieur
le Président merci monsieur le garde des
saau pour vos explications on leevit
l'actualité nous rappelle en permanence
que l'école de la République est
attaquée le 30 novembre 2023 une
trentaine d'enseignants ont manifesté
devant le collège Cléber à Strasbourg
pour soutenir un de leurs collègues
menacés de
quelques jours plus tôt par un élève le
13 décembre 2023 une enseignante
d'anglais a été menacée avec un couteau
en classe par une élève à Renn et
c'était juste 2 mois jour pour jour
après l'assassinat du professeur
Dominique Bernard et quasiment 3 ans
après l'assassinat du professeur Samuel
paatti les syndicats et les professeurs
réclament plus de moyens notamment pour
la prévention et à la fois plus de
moyens et plus de prévention en gros un
professeur sur deux se dit avoir été
victime d'agression physique ou verbale
aujourd'hui ce sont les chiffres
deolipop le droit de retrait de plus en
plus utilisé par les enseignants et donc
à travers ce tableau on constate
qu'effectivement l'école est devenue un
territoire où le où le terrorisme est
euh est vraiment très présent donc je
voudrais juste revenir peut-être sur
deux dispositifs que vous avez évoqué le
déli d'entrave à la fonction
d'enseignant ça a été adopté dans la loi
confortant le le des principes de la
République je crois me souvenir que le
gouvernement n'était pas forcément
favorable à ce délit d'entrave à la
fonction d'enseignant donc je voudrais
juste savoir pas tout à fait au départ
puisque ça a été introduit par les
députés à l'Assemblée nationale oui
finalement on a par non mais voilà donc
voilà bon ben très bien et sur le délis
d'intrusion dans les établissement
scolaire moi quelques quelques mois
quelques années après ces DISP la mise
en place de ces dispositifs dans la loi
je voudrais savoir quel bilan vous
dressez si vous êtes totalement
convaincu par ces mesures désormais et
puis vous demandez quels moyens sont
imaginés pour à la fois renforcer la
prévention et renforcer les moyens que
réclament les enseignants je vous
remercie et enfin Lord Arcos
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre j'ai manqué le
début de votre intervention donc
j'espère que vous ne l'aviez pas déjà
dit moi je voudrais vous parler aussi
des parents parce que on parle beaucoup
euh des élèves mais euh des parents euh
qui viendraient agresser des professeurs
les menacer euh ils ne sont pas soumis
euh un règlement intérieur on a eu
quelques interventions euh en début de
semaine avec d'autres orateurs qui nous
on parlent autant dans le privé il y a
une un règlement qui est enfin une
contractualisation hein entre les
familles et et les établissements autant
dans le l'école laïque républicaine ça
n'est pas le cas euh qu'est-ce qu'il y
est en tout cas prévu pour eux pour en
sanction comment on peut les poursuivre
euh et moi je redemande à nos deux
présidents j'aimerais bien qu'on puisse
voir les associations de parents
d'élèves notamment la FCPE qui à
plusieurs reprises euh se sont illustré
par des campagnes assez
antillaïqu et donc j'aimerais bien qu'on
puisse aussi les recevoir je pense que
ça sera important dans le casadre de
notre commission d'enquête mais Monsieur
le Ministre là c'est surtout par rapport
à à ce que l'on on pourrait faire contre
les parents qui ne sont du coup dans ce
cas-là pas un modèle pour leurs
enfants voilà Monsieur le Ministre les
différentes questions s' en a pas
d'autres je ne crois pas
merciessayer de répondre à toutes les
questions qui m'ont été posées puis si
par
impossible j'oublie une question vous me
rappellerez évidemment à l'ordre bon
peut-être d'abord la prise en charge des
victimes question que et la façon dont
les protocoles sont mis en
place je vais résumer l'instruction
interministérielle intérieur et duucnat
et et et justice du mois d'octobre
2020 l'enseignant victime doit je je je
l'ai dit signaler lesffet à sa
hiérarchie
non je je l'ai dit trois fois pardon je
je mais évidemment si on signale rien on
peut rien faire c'est une évidence bon
euh la hiérarchie informe alors
l'enseignant de son droit de déposer
plainte et d'être
accompagné dans sa démarche par la
direction du service départemental de
l'Éducation
nationale
la plainte doit être prise par un
policier ou un gendarme référent et
cette notion de gendarme
policier parquetier
référent c'est une notion importante
parce que ça implique des
facto une spécialisation et et et
comment
dirais-je une une attention particulière
que l'on va porter bien sûr à la à la
situation l'enseignant est ensuite
orienté vers l'association locale d'aide
aux
victimes lorsque la protection de
l'enseignant apparaît nécessaire je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure sa
domiciliation devient le le l'école ou
le commissariat ou la gendarmerie pour
j'allais dire le mieux protéger
bon voilà ce que ce qui a été mis en
place l'idée vous avez compris c'est que
aucun de ces faits ne se perde et que
l'on puisse intervenir bon les agents de
l'éducation nationale disposent par
ailleurs d'un dispositif
spécifique ils disposent de la
protection
fonctionnelle évidemment mise en œuvre
par leur administration et à ce titre
encore ils sont orientés conseillés et
guidés et à cela vient s'ajouter la
prise en charge qui est offerte à toutes
les victimes d'une infraction
possibilité d'être accompagné tout au
long de la procédure pénale par une
association d'aide au te susceptible de
leur apporter un concours juridique une
assistance sociale psychologique et un
premier contact pouvant se faire
notamment via les bureaux d'aide aux
victimes situés dans les tribunaux
judiciaires enfin pour être complet la
protection fonctionnelle est une
question qui relève de la compétence du
ministre et du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale mais les recteurs doivent
mettre en œuvre à chaque fois que cela
est nécessaire la protection juridique
qui est prévu par une loi du 13 juillet
1983 qui précise que la collectivité
publique est tenue de protéger les
fonctionnaires contre les menaces
violences injur diffamation outrage dont
il pourrait être les victimes à
l'occasion de leur fonction et de
réparer le cas échéant le préjudice qui
en
résulte madame madame la
sénatrice Marie Mercier
ouioui je l'ai vu bien sûr
oui bon moi je suis bien triste que on
ne puisse plus
[Musique]
entendre cette très belle chanson de
Nougaro qui est vraiment en plus une une
une un message entier raciste s'il en
est elle est sublime cette chanson bon
et si j'ai bien compris c'est le
allelluia qui fait ticket
bon alors alors la réponse c'est c'est
praf parce que face à une attitude comme
celle-là il faut qu'on aille voir de
plus près et si vous me permettez cette
familiarité il faut qu'on gratte un peu
parce que qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière
ce refus
obstiné borné et sans doute stupide de
ne pas vouloir entendre une
chanson bah il y a peut-être quelque
chose
d'inquiétant donc il faut aller voir et
c'est pr je l'ai expliqué tout à l'heure
C destiné à décel les signaux qui
pourrai évidemment nous intéresser pour
intervenir et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
après par
exemple si on considère que
l'enfant n'est pas comment
dirais-je élevé comme il pourrait l'être
et que il y a un danger pour l'enfant on
peut aussi saisir
évidemment la protection judiciaire de
la
jeunesse et l'enfant peut-être si c'est
nécessaire placer dans un foyer on n'est
pas là dans de la procédure pénale
encore on est dans de la protection mais
il faut qu'on aille voir évidemment ce
qui se passe et comment les choses bon
donc c'est PRF c'est la réponse si je
dois vous répondre en un
mot en insigle c'est celui-là madame la
sénatrice que je
choisis ensuite il y a les
expériences qui ont été
conduites à Amien notamment Colmar
mulouse également
euh parquet Damien Le daen de la Somme
ça a été conclu en
2020 Colmar Mulous convention avec les
services de l'éducation nationale pour
lutter contre les violences scolaires
2022 je n'ai pas encore de
chiffres parce qu'il faut le temps que
les chiffres
remontent j'ai d'excellents échos en
revanche mais je ne peux pas les
objectiver par des données
chiffrées
mais l'idée pour moi c'est
que ce
rapprochement enfin l'éducation
nationale ne peut pas être comment
dirais-je face à elle-même quand il y a
des menaces des inv des invectives des
violences ou ou malheureusement des
actes beaucoup plus grave s'il s'agit
évidemment de d'actes de nature
criminelle bien sûr que le parquet sera
obligatoirement nécessairement saisie
mais toutes ces petites entorses qui
parfois constituent des infractions et
qui nous choquent les uns et les autres
parce que les profs ils sont pas là pour
se faire insulter menacer voilà ils ont
ils ont un programme pédagogique dedans
il peut y avoir une chanson de de
lougaro
ou une
toile bon donc
l'idée c'est que tous les partenariats
et moi je suis très attaché à cela je
l'ai déjà dit et dans d'autres domaines
préfecture force de sécurité intérieure
magistrat tout ça ça
doit ça ne peut plus être dans la
culture du silo ça doit travailler
ensemble on a déjà eu d'ailleurs à
regarder ces questions je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure mais je le redis dans dans
dans dans ces affaires de
violence intrafamilial on a eu quelques
exemples où l'on ne se parlait pas et on
a eu des catastrophes en
réalité tout le monde a l'esprit mgque
et mgenque après une expertise très
approfondie de l'inspection générale de
la justice il y a pas de faute
individuelle mais il y a une espèce de
culture dans laquelle une habitude qui
fait qu'on se parle pas et qu'on se
donne pas les informations et c'est ça
l'objet de de de ces protocoles et de
ces conventions c'est d'échanger dès la
moindre alerte et parfois même et je
l'ai dit sans qu'il y ait une alerte par
des relations régulières entre le
rectorat justice le référent parquet qui
fait le tour des écoles au fond pour
savoir comment les choses se
passent on m'a également posé une une
une
question monsieur le sénateur levrier
sur est-ce que est-ce que l'école
privée la réponse est oui
évidemment toute l'éducation nationale
mais t tous les établissements de
formation voilà sens plus
large ensuite il y a une question à
laquelle je peux pas répondre il il en
fallait une monsieur le sénateur
Piednoir mais vous me pardonnerez sur le
droit de retrait faut demander à Gabriel
je pense que vous allez le l'entendre si
prochainement bon c'est lui qui est bon
je également vous dire voyez sur ces
partenariats
entre les force de sécurité intérieure
magistrat parquet on on met en place
exactement la même chose là pour ces
histoires de
harcèlement d'ailleurs j'ai fait quelque
chose qui n'avait jamais été fait à la
Chancellerie avec Gabriel et et Gabriel
Atal et et Gérald dararmanin on a réuni
les procureurs les procureurs généraux
qui ont ouvert un peu les yeux parce que
ils ont vu deux autres ministres que
leur ministre de tutelle ça ne s'était
jamais fait et moi je trouvais que cette
ce partage entre l'intérieur
euh pardonnez-moi et et et
et les les procureurs bah c'était très
intéressant et très riche et les ducnat
et les procureurs et làppeil on a mis en
place des référents et tout un système
bah pour ne plus qu'on ait les drames
auxquels on a
assisté voilà pour aider aussi les chefs
d'établissements à à à distinguer ce qui
peut-être une chamaillerie d'un
harcèlement et comment on le prend en
compte et comment on le prend en compte
rapidement pour éviter que on est c'est
ces suicides de jeunes là qui sont enfin
qui qui qui qui sont des choses
absolument insupportables pour nous
alors les magistrats ils ont été surpris
de voir le ministre de l'Intérieur et et
le ministre de l'éducation nationale et
les choses se sont passées
formidablement bien c'était de vrais
échanges bon moi j'avais été devant les
préfets ce qui était aussi totalement
novateur mais voilà il faut je pense
qu'il faut que on partage les
informations à tout niveau d'ailleurs au
niveau ministériel avec vous avec et
puis sur le terrain c'est bon c'est une
façon d'être d'être d'être plus efficace
euh quelle question n'ai-je pas encore
répondu la question de Monique dearco
oui
je peux reposer ma dans le micro oui je
peux reposer ma question parce que vous
avez parléune procédure idéale oui moi
je vais pas chipoter mais quand vous
êtes enseignant c'est pas toujours
facile que la hiérarchie puisse relayer
vos préoccupations et donc les problèmes
que vous avez eu d'agression donc moi je
voulais savoir s'il était possible pour
un enseignant Madame B dans voilà de
d'avoir un policier référent qui
pourrait alerter directement ou une
personne dans le domaine de la justice
et ensuite deè deuxè peut-on saisir
directement le pôle national de lutte
contre la haine en ligne et sur les 2000
et quelques procédures combien
d'enseignantsir vous avez raison de de
me reposer la question parce que j'ai
j'ai j'ai oublié de vous dire et c'est
impartonnable qui a un site
masécurité.fr quel l'enseignant peut
aller
directement jeis vous faire précis ah
oui c'est important et ensuite oubl
l'essentiel mais voilà donc et ensuite
quand il a voilà ce que j'aurais voulu
vous m'expliquer quand il a alerté sur
ce site là quelle est donc la possédure
comment cela se met en
place une fois que les faits ont été
portés à la connaissance du gendarme ou
du du du policier évidemment il il il
essaie de de Al d'identifier l'auteur
s'il est pas identifié les choses se
mettent en route et puis le parquet est
saisi puis le parquet apporte ensuite
une réponse naturellement qui peut
peut-être si l'auteur n'est pas
identifié ou si les faits ne sont pas
suffisamment caractérisés une un
classement sans suite mais voyez par
exemple j'ai des j'ai un exemple très
précis là Gabriel Atal m'avait saisi
d'uneun exemple je veux pas m'y arrêter
mais voilà des
enseignants qui se plaignent auprès du
parquet et qui dénonce des faits et le
parquet estime que euh ça n'est pas
constitutif d'une infraction pénale bon
et la frustration vient du fait que le
parquet
tardivement va expliquer pour quelle
raison il y a eu un classement sans
suite et pendant cette période c'est une
vraie période de frustration parce que
euh Gabriel me dit mais mes profs ils
disent mais pourquoi le parquet ne nous
on a c'est d'ailleurs une des questions
qu'on a évoqué dans cette réunion qu'on
a faite bon euh c'est pour ça que euh
c'est c'est très intéressant cette idée
du référent parce que le référent il
sait naturellement par
définition que l'enseignant il attend
une réponse l'enseignant il attend pas
forcément qu'on lui dise les faits sont
avérés il peut entendre que c'est un
classement sans suite mais il faut qu'on
lui explique et il faut au moins qu'il
ait la certitude ça pour moi c'est
essentiel que la justice a traiter les
choses qu'ensuite pas forcément une
condamnation au bout d'une plainte tout
le monde le sait il y a même parfois un
classement sans suite qui intervient
mais pour de multiples raisons mais il
faut qu'on ait cette explication pour ça
que cette idée du référent que les gens
se parle et ben elle est pour moi
essentielle
euh vous m'avez également posé
[Musique]
euh oui pardon vous vous m'aviez
également demandé madame la sénatrice le
pôle n n en ligne comment on saisit
c'est Faros qui saisit
d'cord votre micro ch collèg parce que
savoir la part de d'enseignants dans
dans le chiffre que vous avez émis
environ environ je je je peux pas vous
dire ça d'accord je je ne l'ai pas on
peut pas les
différencier non euh c'est répertorié
comme des faits constitutifs de haine en
ligne bon mais on peut pas euh dire ces
faits euh ces injures cette haine a été
à destination d'un enseignant
non l'intérieur peut le dire l'Intérieur
a ces chiffres là nous on les a
pas
euh madame madame la S sénatrice
D'cos vous m'avez demandé si si je me
permets de résumer cette question et
puis si elle est trop trop trop résumé
vous vous m'interrompez infraction
pénale contre des enseignants du privé
si j'ai bien compris
euh non non non non c'est simplement
parce que dans le privé les parents
enfin la famille signne des enfin
contractualise avec l'école pas dans
l'école laïque en fait où il n'y a pas
def les parents n'ont pasigné un
règlement intérieur comme le font les
enfants si vous voulez euh dans dans
dans par rapport à leur à leur
professeurs donc ils sont entre
guillemets extérieurs à l'établissement
mais on voit de plus en plus d'agression
verbale et physique de parents sur les
sur les professeurs est-ce qu'on est
dans la même exactement la même
configuration que d'acordou oui bien sûr
bien sûr oui oui
euh je veux également vous dire
là sur les comportements de
gamin qui nous inquiète et qui nous
interpelle
on a mis en place avec Gabriel Atal vous
savez c'est la question
de le gamin qui refuse la minute de
silence bon il y en a quelques-uns
bon donc
là-dessus on va évidemment au
disciplinaires très bien
et là-dessus il y a aussi le réflexe
c'estprf allez voir ce qui se passe là
derrière et est-ce qu'on est en train de
faire de ce gamin moi je vous parle
cache un islamo au quel cas il est en
danger et il faut
l'extraire de ce milieu qui deviendra un
milieu mortifère en tous les cas ça
n'est pas supportable on est tous
d'accord là-dessus intervention de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
donc on va on veut aller assez loin dans
ces pour lutter contre ces comportements
on peut pas on peut pas dire bon mais
voilà
une petite sanction à l'école et au
revoir où on change de d'établissement
scolaires bon ce qui fait partie
d'ailleurs des des des mesures utilisées
aujourd'hui davantage qu'autrefois mais
en même
temps on a sur le volet
préventif un regard attentif à
exercer madame
billon oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le gardau je je vous avais
interrogé sur le bilan que vous pouviez
dresser à la fois du dél d'entrave à la
fonction d'enseignant et le délis
d'intrusion dans l'é dans un
établissement scolaire donc quel bilan
en tiriez-vous et euh quels moyens
supplémentaires on pouvait imaginer pour
la prévention dans les établissements
scolaires je vous
remercie j'ai pas répondu à votre
question par que je suis incapable de le
faire non mais j'ai pas les chiffres
mais je vous les communiquerai puisque
s'il y a eu des condamnations si elles
sont intervenues sont répertorié au
casier judiciaire national donc là on
pourra avoir les chiffres je vous dirai
comment on a appliqué ces textes mais je
sais qu'ils ont été naturellement
appliqués et quant à la question que
vous me posiez
sur la la circonspection qui a pu être
la mienne je je vous avoue que après
avoir
entendu les arguments de madame
jeunevard euh naturellement on a été
convaincu la la question était de savoir
on on on on partait dans mon souvenir et
pardon si mes propos ne sont pas exat
mais le le le débat parlementaire date
mais je peux être contredit là à
l'instant je je l'accepte
volontiers nous avions d'abord envisager
la protection des
FSI et ensuite c'était posé la question
d'autres protections mais si tout le
monde fait l'objet d'une protection
alors le texte n'est plus une exception
c'était ça la discussion qui avait eu
lieu et très vite on a compris l'intérêt
qu'il y avait d'inclure si j'ose dire
les enseignants dans la protection qui
était une protection en faveur à
l'origine des forces de sécurité
intérieure voilà le souvenir que j'ai du
débat mais on a vite entendu raison
Madame la
Sénat bien mes chersègues encore une
question en prie euh monsieur le
ministre Messieurs les Présidents euh on
a beaucoup parlé des partenariats
justice ministère de l'Intérieur
éducation nationale euh nous sommes la
chambre des territoires quel rôle
peuvent jouer les élus et monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie effectivement
pour l'ouverture de la justice en terme
de communication auprès des élus locaux
dans le cadre de l'éducation nationale
et effectivement des violences entre
guillemets vis-à-vis des enseignants je
pense que les élus locaux ont
probablement un moment donné donner un
rôle à jouer comment comment est-ce que
ça peut
s'articuler sur le sur le terrain et et
en particulier avec les ministères
concernés madame la sénatrice votre
question est en plein dans mon actualité
si j'ose dire parce que j'ai rédigé une
plaquette à la tension des maires
euh pour essayer de les de les aider
[Musique]
dans les difficultés qu'il rencontrre à
la fois quand ils sont évidemment
victimes puis que nous savons qu'il y a
une une multiplication de ces de ces
comportements
antirépublicains mais aussi qu'est-ce
que c'est pour un maire qui n'a pas
l'expérience qu'est-ce que c'est d'être
officier de police judiciaire euh il y a
un certain nombre de questions qui sont
abordées comme ça de façon assez
complète me semble-t-il bon l'œil ne se
regarde pas voir si vous me permettez
cette expression mais on a essayé d'être
complet pour que nos lu é un petit
livret un petit guide bon et il y a une
médiation avec les familles qui est
possible et qui est des fois
extraordinairement
utile
d'ailleurs nous avons déjà avec la
première ministre annoncé un certain
nombre de mesures poste émeute il y a ce
volet là qui reviendra aussi c'estàdire
poste émeute sous le sous l'angle
parentalité l'idée je je l'ai exprimé à
l'Assemblée nationale à suite d'une
question question qui m'a été posée
c'est à la
fois de de sanctionner les parents
défaillant
mais de ne pas sanctionner les parents
dépassés pas tout à fait la même chose
on va quand même pas all les
sanctionnner la maman qui élève son
gamin toute seule dans le poste émeut on
s'est rendu compte après analyse que
vous aviez un pourcentage
extraordinairement élevé je pense que
c'est près de 60 % de de gamin élevé
seul enfin élevé par un seul parent
pardon
donc je pense que les mères ont un les
les élus ont un vrai rôle à jouer bien
sûr et il faut qu'on aille aussi sur ce
terrain de la parentalité non
pas comme l'extrême gauche nous le
reproche d'une façon absolument
caricaturale mais je pense qu'il faut
oui je le dis aider les parents qui sont
dépassés et rappeler aux parents qui
sont défaillants ou des inv volte et qui
mettent en danger la moralité de leur
gamin il faut leur rappeler de trois
obligations parce que cela et c'est en
lien direct avec notre sujet même si je
n'entendais pas évoquer ça ce soir on
les retrouve à l'école quand même tout
ça c'est c'est la même boucle hein
euh donc voilà
euh ce que ce que ce que je peux dire
sur le rôle des des des élus et en
particulier des maires et pour ne rien
vous cacher d'ailleurs madame la
sénatrice l'idée elle est née
d'une réunion qui a été faite qui a été
conduite sous l'gite de la première
ministre à matigon on a reçu des maires
qui ont expliquer d'ailleurs comment il
pouvaent intervenir parfois comme
médiateur entre les familles et
arranger ma grand-mère aurait dit
arranger les bidon et et c'est utile oui
bien sûr et on ne peut pas perdre ça
parce que là aussi ça va dans le sens de
tout le monde travaille ensemble
l'objectif il est commun et les élus ils
ont évidemment une part importante dans
cette possible possible
médiation ministre une dernière question
de notre collègue jean-chard Pomier
c'est la dernière merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
voudrais revenir un instant sur
l'anecdote de notre collègue j'ai bien
compris votre propos en disant il faut
creuser derrière la réaction de parents
par rapport à la chanson de Louis
Armstrong mais moi ce qui me pose aussi
problème c'est la réaction de
l'inspecteur en disant on va chanter
lalala parce que là j'y vois comment
dire
un problème entre le papier qui sur le
papier et la réalité sur le papier tous
les dispositifs apparemment fonctionnent
la réalité tout à fait différente et
comme président de département j'étais
confronté m fois à des situations dont
disais oh pas de vague c'est la
tentation de le gérer en silo éducation
nationale et de dire pas pas de vague
est-ce pas de vague en considérant que
ce n'est pas grave que c'est un premier
signe qu'on verra la prochaine fois et
je pense effectivement il y a beaucoup
de gris c'est pas noir ou blanc mais je
pense qu'il y a quand même souvent dans
l'éducation n nationale la volonté de le
traiter en interne là où comme vous le
dites justement il faut le gérer à
plusieurs justice éducation et
intérieure merci Monsieur le Ministre
euh monsieur le
[Musique]
sénateur je suis pas ministre de
l'éducation nationale mais
mais je sais pas quoi madame brigot
bonantl on peut on peut on peut on peut
se dire des choses avant Noël oui oui
mais peut-être pas celle-là
bon non mais écoutez je pas ministre de
l'éducation nationale mais enfin comme
vous le dites c'est lesducnat qui cède
parce qu'un gamin veut pas entendre une
chanson qui appartient à notre
patrimoine c'est c'est c'est c'est
pardon c'est lunaire mais moi je veux
vous dire que ce que nous avons fait au
ministère de la Justice ce que fait
Gabriel àal ce que fait
Gal c'est que le pas de vague n'a plus
aucune raison de perdurer en tous les
cas on fait tout pour qu'il ait des
vagues maintenant voilà et qu'elle soit
porté à la connaissance de tout le
monde
voilà
merci mais pour être parfaitement
net par rapport au VAG l'enjeu c'est de
ne jamais
je crois qu'on a a l'impérieuse
nécessité de
réarmer moralement intellectuellement y
compris politiquement dans le bon sens
du terme l'ensemble de nos concitoyenss
services la circonstance pour ne pas
reculer un pas en arrière même un demi
pas c'est déjà une défaite et
mercistrong belle soirée à vous nous
allons lever la séance merci à
vous